Saudi Arabia says Yemen's Houthi rebels
have hijacked a vessel south of the Red
Sea the ship was towing a South Korean
drilling rig the Saudi News Agency says
a group of armed Houthi rebels seized
the vessel on Sunday Houthi official has
told reuters they will release the
vessel if they can confirm it belongs to
South Korea Mohamed Al Attar joins us
live from the Yemeni capital sana
Mohamed what more can you tell us about
this and apparently involves a South
Korean vessel yes the healthiest have
already confirmed that we have already
confiscated two military vehicles or
shrubs in the Yemeni regional waters
they say that this is a custom or
procedure that the carry-outs once they
find out any foreign or strange boats on
Yemeni international waters this is
according to the Hafiz
source he has confirmed that the we are
ready to handle or release there is a
reg that has been that could be called
or requested by the southern Koreans if
this we are still these news are still
so not confirmed that what they said
that Lisa T these two results are from
multinational they have their multi
nationalities but they cannot could not
couldn't confirm that it belongs to the
southern Korean and it's also a reg but
to my source that have talked to me that
we he said that this we have found out
an oil rag Allah along with the the two
vessels the same source also wondered
why the international community
especially that such outcry has been has
been called over this issue of chemists
aiding confiscating two military ships
once the Yemenis have been unable to
enter oil ships into the Haditha
seaports even these oil shipments have
been permitted by the United Nations and
then
and there later on they were banned by
the Saudi authorities so Muhammad let's
just be clear about this now they are
confirming that they have this ship and
it is a South Korean ship and it was
towing something as well I want to be
clear on what the process is from here
and when and under what circumstances it
will be released yes the the source that
I have talked to was from the healthy's
told me that the if the southern Korean
Korea called for the release of its oil
wreck they would do so after after
taking out or hang out the paperwork or
the or the official contacts between
them in order to confirm the the the
these this oil rag belongs to South
Korea but their houses themselves have
not yet officially speaking about these
circumstances why we have canvassed
kated these these two vessels but the
source from the Houthis told me that the
we have carry that is a usual measure
that they are they are carrying outs by
themselves once they find out any
foreign or strange vessels and the
Yemeni regional waters ok Muhammad will
leave it there of course we come back to
if we find out anything more in this
story